novak and his team filed the same type  of documents as those 25 other tennis  players and they didn't have any  problems just novak  they wanted to humiliate him  they could have said don't come novak  and that would have been okay  but no they wanted to humiliate him  and they're still keeping him in prison  he's not in detention he's in prison  they took all of his stuff even his  wallet they left him with just a phone  and no change of clothes nowhere to wash  his face  he's in prison our pride is a prisoner  of these idiots  shame on them  the whole free world together with  serbia should rise this isn't a battle  for serbia  it's a battle for seven or something  billion people for freedom of expression  free speech freedom of behavior  novak didn't break any laws just as  seven billion people didn't break any  laws they want to subdue us and for us  all on our knees it won't fly  freedom novak we're all with you